who everybody how's everybody doing I
hope you've been fine okay I just want
to announce first that Friday there I'm
gonna have a little interview for those
of you who are interested in
understanding a little more maybe
perhaps depending on how the heat energy
goes about the extinction of man the
very likely upcoming imminent extinction
of man theory I have now for twenty
years well then you can tune in I'm
going to be putting a link in patron in
in Facebook so those of you follow me
there well you'll know where to uh how
to tune in anyways that's going to be on
Friday it's gonna be at six o'clock in
the evening
UTC Zulu time okay so you're interested
in the extinction what this coronavirus
thing will be triggering possibly you
know then it's a good time to tune in
anyways what I'm going to talk about
today is about motion and how it's
changed through the ages and it's really
quite funny to see all the notions of
motion that we've had I'm going to start
with the common someone made a comment
on the word concept okay and I want to
clarify that okay so here's the here's
the comment says can a concept be
described by one object plus a concept a
day-old Apple for example right the same
Apple that is two days old do you mean
that in this case the Apple is two
objects or does the one Apple object
right and the passage of time concept
define a concept specific passage of
time yeah we have to remember that a
concept is already a relationship
between
two objects made by a conscious observer
so a concept already embodies objects so
yeah you can say that you can compare an
object against the concept if that makes
any sense but the object the concept
itself already has two objects in it
okay and yeah and here's a pictorial
representation of an answer to this
fellow's question here you have this is
motion but it applies anyways here we
have a movie of motion we have three
frames in this filmstrip okay and so the
issue here is that that box is the same
box in each one of the frames it's just
a different times different locations
right it suffered motion there's
different distances between it and
assuming all these other objects are
standing still completely still in the
universe it's moving with respect to
them it's changing its distance with
respect each one of those objects so
yeah it's the same box and what we would
be comparing is the box under in this
case in the third frame were the one on
the first frame its we're treating them
as two separate objects simply because
they have different locations we're
talking about two things we're making a
comparison you can only compare two you
can't compare it one if you have a
single box in the universe that's all
God made there's nothing to compare it
with there's no distance because again
you distance is a concept that requires
two day objects and here there's there's
only a box so it has no location again
that requires more than one object etc
etc etc so yeah if you match it against
a concept there's no difference really
okay no change there okay let's get on
with it I left the other day with a good
old Aristotle and I'm just going to
summarize his notions of place first of
all of object of what an object is then
of place time in motion okay and so here
they are you know
so this would have covered last couple
sessions
what's a body or a thing an entity a
medium yeah because all those words mean
the same thing in physics according to
rational physics and it's bounded by a
surface and that's that's pretty good
I've got no problem with that that's at
least very close to the definition that
we're looking for unfortunately he
didn't pay any attention to it nobody
did in ancient times they never realized
how important that word was for the
purposes of physics you need to have an
object a body a thing in order to do
physics you can't do physics without a
thing with absolutely nothing out there
in the universe they never figure that
out okay and so they always kept
inventing this ether stuff the little
particles that are in the background
because they'd never knew or never
understood never figured out what space
is okay that's it place where this place
places the boundary of the body which
contains it okay so you say it's the
hole where you put the ball and when you
pull the ball out and you leave a hole
well that's that's the place but it's
it's only a place when the ball is in
there when you remove it it becomes a
void so there's a difference between
areas language right between void and
and place okay okay he continues just in
case you missed it he says place is the
boundary itself okay
and here he specified so that you can't
miss it place can be left behind by the
thing and is separable okay so it's the
hole that you leave behind that's called
place time when it's time time is a
measure of motion okay measure of motion
time is number I I think the translation
is wrong I put them out there I think it
sounds better
it's amount of motion okay and he
clarifies time is not movement but only
movement insofar as it admits of
enumeration okay what is motion change
of place what's the problem there the
word change changes already motion
and that's essentially you know where he
made his there well one of his errors
okay but everybody who inherited this
stuff from him ended up you know using
the same essentially the same
definitions here you have the modern
definitions side by side well not side
by side doesn't matter here what does it
object anything these are definitions
from dictionaries Wikipedia etc right
and the ones you'll find on the Internet
the first ones that appear so this is
the notion people have out there and
he's these are the notions that the math
magicians use okay because you won't
find a definition for these words
officially out there okay anyway he's
object anything that is visible or
tangible absolutely not that's not a
what an object is but in ordinary speech
you can say that not in science not in
physics I not teach that which has
shaped not that which can be touched or
seen okay but you can see that those are
the definitions they have take a
material thing I like the fact that
they're using anything thing they're
using synonyms to define whatever we
want to define you can't use the word
thing that you find the word thing
object is a thing so you can't use the
word thing a material thing that can be
seen and touched and the other issue is
material material is always bunch of
objects that exist so its materials just
a bunch of objects so you can't use that
word either to define the word option
another one object collection of matter
again matter you can't use that word
because matter is objects okay and
collection is wrong also because that's
me rheology that's saying that a table
is a billion atoms and a and I don't
know maybe a ball is also a billion
atoms so what's the difference between
these two billion atoms if if an object
is just a billion atoms what are you
going to count them or what so you can't
use me realities you can't say an object
is what it's made of
that's me rheology okay its religion
position which is the more or less the
notion I guess that
area wanted to convey regarding place he
says hey you can t vector vectors motion
and there's gonna scribe position which
is supposedly a static concept they're
not defined in terms of vector which is
displacement okay that represents the
position of a point I like the fact they
use a synonym position to define
position was a point it's also position
because it's a location right so it's
what you put to designate a location you
ask them what's the point well here's
the thigh what does it that well it's
really representing the location so all
these are centum they're circular
definitions not one of these passes
scientific criteria motion is the change
again where they get that from girl Airy
nothing changed in two thousand years
yeah changing the position of an object
over time they need they use the word
time to define motion when motion should
be defined before time what has changed
also something blah blah blah blah blah
time so these people defining motion in
terms of time so how do you find time
well hopefully they define in terms of
motion so they're gonna have a circular
definition you can't use the word time
to define motion what's time the system
of those sequential relations that's any
event has to any other time is the
indefinitely continued progress of
existence okay and events time is the
progression of events from the past to
the present into the future
whatever those are because past present
future already involved the word time
embodies who were times he can't use
those words to define time time is
defined by its measurement this is the
these last two by the way are from
physics supposedly physic mathematical
physics defined by its measurement time
is what a clock reads I don't know my
clock in never is illiterate never went
to school
so my clock doesn't read anything so
yeah we we don't have rational
definitions from the mathematical
establishment that's that's a big
problem because it shows that these
people
never learned how to define words
scientifically that's what it stands for
it that's the result today we have no
definitions for these words no
scientific definitions now we don't care
about the word time because we have no
use for it in physics that's in religion
where we use the word time in physics in
science you got to explain a phenomenon
time hat does not help us explain any
phenomenon time is a mathematical
description of whatever we've already
defined time so I'm not going to go over
that but it's a mathematical description
it's a number line that's what it is
that's what time is a comparison of two
motions okay things did not stay like
this forever some people did analyze
Airy and also played on some of the
other Greeks and Aristotle because he
was probably the one the the one who did
the best job in putting all this
together and because we found his books
because we have no books from Democritus
and they say he wrote just about as much
or maybe more than Aristotle okay so one
guy that analyzed the area was this guy
here st. Augustine of Hippo okay and he
said the following very interesting way
of thinking okay he says let no man then
tell me that the motions of the heavenly
bodies constitute times okay because
when at the prayer of one and he's going
to refer to Joshua when he prayed for
the Sun to stand still in the sky the
Sun had stood still till he could
achieve his victorious battle the Sun
Stood Still but time went on okay so
what was this all about well his
reasoning is look you've got you've got
the heavenly bodies you know in the Sun
at least in the flat earth goes over the
over the the sky right and moves around
right and comes back the next morning or
whatever okay so the Sun moves right
around the earth and so does the moon
right according that's how these guys
are looking at this right
and you know Joshua told the Sun to
stand still or at least ask God to make
it stand still God conceded his wish and
he was able to defeat I think it was the
Philistines right and and so what
happened well the Sun Stood Still and
they fought so so you know we had no
motion of the heavens which is how we
used to measure time right but there was
still I mean you know we had motion
there and the motion had stopped but
time went on and so he suggests and
that's gonna be taken over also by st.
Thomas who comes in next in the analysis
when when you know you have this motion
going on now it's stopped time continues
and what these guys are gonna have in
the back of their mind is that motion
belongs to the object time is something
external to the objects okay
other than decay right but in general
when we talk about time you talk about
something external to the objects the
object does the motion it's like I said
the other day the moon moves but you ask
the moon how much time it took the moon
has no idea the moon makes no
comparisons the moon only knows that it
moves and that's all that we have out
there in the universe we have motion but
time time is here down here in in our
brains
there's no such thing as time up there
you know moving around or doing
something okay so it's important to keep
that distinction
okay here's Tommy st. Thomas Aquinas
okay and he did a little bit of analysis
on motion and time as well and the son
Summa Theologica
matter was in some measure formulas you
remember these guys get a lot of this
stuff from the Bible okay so keep that
in the back of your mind matter was in
some measure formless before it received
its full form okay silly putty you mold
it right so time was in a manner
formless before it was fully formed and
distinguished into day and night you
know God separated day and from nine he
says that in the Bible gay
time is nothing else than the measure of
priority and succession of movement okay
so again these people are relating it to
motion okay that's important but it's
the measure of motion that's what he's
saying that time is and that's more or
less the notion we you know the
mathematicians have today among the
first created things are tube you reckon
those which have a general relationship
to things and therefore among these time
must be included as having the nature of
a common measure but not movement which
is related only to the move movable
subject okay objects move they don't do
time only prisoners do time okay that's
that's his his logic essentially okay
he's saying you know time is not exactly
the same as motion there's a little bit
of difference but they never figured
that out they never realized what they
were saying they never had a definition
for their own word for time because we
don't use time in physics but obviously
these people in mathematical physics and
in religion they like time so much well
then define it you know and this is what
he says next here we have kind of like
wrapping it up right places implied as
existing in the empyrion heaven okay
this being the boundary of the universe
so if you always want to know if the
universe has an edge yeah it is the edge
is known as heaven and since place has
reference to things permanent it was
created at once in its totality if God
did it all at once okay but time is not
being permanent it's always moving
what's created in its beginning the
beginning of time right
even as actually we cannot lay hold of
any part of time save that now okay so
that's the only part we can experience
that now we don't experience the whole
interval of time from past the future
we only know except maybe in our brains
we remember but we live or experience at
the cutting edge of time you can say
between the
that edge between the past in the future
that's where we're at we all we're
always in the present and that's known
as location if if god were to stop the
universe right from moving the hole
every little bit of matter just stop
something just freezes in place we have
no time but what you have is location
okay everything is located if there's
distance between everything and there is
location that's all you have that's
that's the cross-section of time okay
that's the notion of cross-section of
time okay here we have mr. Descartes he
came a couple centuries later okay and
he he does a little bit of analysis also
on some of the basics of what he thought
were physical was physics remember he
was considered a philosopher okay I
don't think he was but he tried to do
philosophy just like Aristotle and their
philosophy was geared or oriented
towards physics right here they might to
understand how this universe worse and
they call that philosophy okay and I've
dealt with that subject in the past okay
but the issue is he wants to define
motion and he first defines in formal
motion then he's gonna define formal
motion ok so here's here's in formal
motion motion is nothing more than this
than the action by which a body passes
from one place to another okay so he
uses the word passes okay so what is
passes its motion so they don't realize
they're using synonyms that we find the
word motion that's that's the big
problem that all these people have they
never were able to separate the word the
key word in their definition which is
already motion some some form of motion
and they never realized that they were
saying it and it happens to all of them
to this day a person seated he gives an
example here a person seated in a vessel
which is setting sail face he is in
motion if he if he looked to the
sure that he has loved and considered as
a as fixed he considers the surface okay
but not if he regards the ship itself
among the parts of which he preserves
always the same situation in other words
if he's inside and a lot of them have
the same notion of Galilei also we'll
have this notion if you're not inside a
boat right inside the room of a boat you
know you're getting farther and farther
from the shore then you're moving with
respect to the shore but you're not
moving supposedly with respect to the
little table that you have inside your
room that's what he's saying and this is
the notion that relativity is gonna pick
up by later on you know because they're
gonna say well what's the frame of
reference is it the shore or is it the
table that's that's what what they're
talking about here okay and he concludes
the person thus seated is more property
said to be at rest and in motion
introduces the observer see he is not
conscious of being in motion again very
dangerous because now he starts to
introduce what the person perceives and
that's a no-no in physics we don't care
about your psychology or philosophy no
no we want to see something objectively
we need to analyze something objectively
and you know he's referring to what the
person perceives he says oh this is
motion to him okay and again this this
is gonna be a serious problem throughout
because to this day we have this
observer problem physics there are no
observers it's all objective no no
subjectivity so what's the formal
definition well here's the card formal
definition of time and as you can see
that I underlined a key word there that
transporting or is it transporting you
already motion see this they keep
messing it up they don't realize it
transporting of one part of matter or of
one body from the vicinity of those
bodies that are in immediate contact
with it or which we regard as at rest
which we regard talking about the
observer again
to the vicinity of other bodies in other
words too many errors and these
definitions because they're not careful
enough in what they're saying the first
thing introduced words that already
embody motion and secondly introduce the
observer and they're all the same to
this day we have this problem okay
and that's why mathematical physics
cannot be part of science great measure
because no definitions and then what
view there are they they introduce
synonyms and and then it all comes down
to opinions they say well what did you
see how much time did you measure well I
measure so much time time is just some
mother well you're correct and I'm Craig
were just it's all relevant all relative
relative it's all relative right that's
what it is and so they leave it at that
and you walk out of there saying what
did we learn today okay now we come to
mr. Galileo he also analyzed the time
motion many motion he was a motion guy
they like they cart more or less and
what does he say well he said he defined
two types of or he distinguished uniform
motion from accelerated motion other
it's acceleration from just uniform
motion okay the steady or uniform motion
by by steady or uniform motion I mean
one in which the distances Traverse by
the moving particle during any equal
integrals of time are themselves equal
so equal x equal distance etc right and
the other hand accelerated motion is is
said to be uniformly excited motion is
said to be uniformly accelerated when
starting from rest it acquires dirty
equal time intervals equal increments of
speed okay so it's speeding always a
given rate it's going faster and faster
and faster and faster okay so he's
talking about speed and acceleration but
see the important part here is that he's
introducing mathematics in he served
mathematics at the problem you can see
the the title of his book discourses and
mathematical demonstrations related to
two new sciences yeah
he was one of the first to say
mathematics is the language of physics
which it ain't but that's how you see
where he came from one important thing
that you should know is that Galileo was
not the first one to do the in other
he's credited with having thrown two
balls from the Tower of Pisa and letting
them fall to the ground one was buried
one was small and they both landed at
the same time so that's how we proved or
demonstrated that lighter objects and
heavier objects barring any friction
fall at the same rate well that's that's
a misconstruction of history it's a
tearing history to pieces and so I just
want to clarify that to whoever's
interested in this in the issue all
these people here they did the the two
ball the small and big ball a
examination or test experiment before
Aaron before Galileo was born okay we
have john philoponus in his theory of
impetus domingo de Soto a Jesuit Spanish
this would and he he also talked about
in his book aside from the fact that he
did the experiment I think he was the
first one to do it the the few balls
okay Girolamo Cardano 'he's also wrote
lots of stuff hardly known by anyone and
he wrote tons he wrote more than Galileo
for sheree bra who was more versatile
than Galileo and for sure Giuseppe
miletti
because miletti he was he was the
professor at Padua University which is
the the position that Galileo took over
when this guy retired so miletti he he
not only was there before galley
Galileo knew him this guy wrote dialogue
on mechanics Galileo was interested in
mechanics it's almost impossible that
gal gadot never read his book miletti's
book or was acquainted with miletti's
you know experiments and his his notions
of mechanics okay and if all that fails
we still have Simon Stevin he's a guy
from Netherlands okay and he wrote a
book you can find it on the internet and
about the weight of water and in there
he he does the experiment he in fact he
draws the picture of you know the tower
and how he did the experiment he did
that in 1586 but well yeah that's when
the book was published he probably did
the experiment two years earlier about
1584 and Galileo was only twenty years
old at the time and so he was just
getting out of school and this guy was
already you know publishing his books oh
no way Galileo was not the first guy to
do the you know the two ball trick
supposedly what Galileo apparently did
was the inclined planes
okay that was told that was his stuff he
had his little he was under house arrest
at the last years of his life and that's
where he worked and that's when he wrote
this book the the one about the
mechanics okay motion okay who came next
well one guy comes next is this fellow I
guess everybody knows him if I can get
him up here and his name is Isaac Newton
and what did Newton contribute to the
science to motion to gravity well very
little he's credited with three laws of
motion two of which were already
analyzed by Descartes before Newton was
born so yeah he was annalen because his
book was written like in the 36:16 30s
late 1630s and Newton was born 1642 so
you know already Descartes had talked
about two of his laws the first and
third law okay
those those he analyzed before Newton
did and one of the reasons that Galileo
became famous and why he's credited with
everything is because of Newton Newton
read Galilean quoted him quite a bit and
Newton was a God in his days so because
of him we know Galileo and we forgot
about all these other fellows who did a
lot of experiments they already had a
lot of the information that Galileo was
later on gonna publish you know and I
guess he got the credit whether he
requested it remind you got the credit
anyways all because of this fall anyways
one thing you should know about
particular there are no equations so
Newton's equation that came later fact
the French were the guys who came up
with all his equations based on his book
game so they put it into little
variables and numbers and so on and all
these equations that they included later
on but no Newton does not have he he
only writes he writes he explains okay
and you know he talks about three laws
of motion he never defined motion he
said I do not define time place place
time space place and motion because we
all know about it here we all know what
they are and so that's a bad way to
start his book he put that in his skull
iam and so you know they how can we
credit him for the three laws of motion
if he doesn't know or doesn't understand
what motion is if he can't define the
word motion and he never did so he got
very little from him in in regards to
motion but here we got a notion that he
really had it wrong and that's in his
first law says everybody contained
everybody continues in its state of rest
there's nothing at rest in the universe
so I don't know what he's talking about
or of uniform motion in a right line
right meaning straight line there's
nothing that moves in a straight line
okay
besides straight is the wrong word it's
called rectilinear motion but that's
aside and that is unless it is compelled
change that state by forces impressed
upon it and so yeah I don't know if we
can credit him with the three laws of
motion that's the British claiming one
of theirs wrongfully making too much of
of Newton but he did invent
instantaneous motion yay and routers
don't like that so they they threw his
instantaneous motion out the window they
said look nothing moves faster than
light okay and so you're wrong Newton
there's no instantaneous motion well
it's done taneous means again
cross-section of time and all you have
there is location okay so you can't have
motion you can't have instantaneous
motion because instantaneous opposed is
a cross-section of an interval of time
whatever that could possibly mean you're
talking again location what can
instantaneous mean so we have a
contradiction when we use the word
instantaneous in conjunction with the
word motion but other than that Newton
was right and relative is wrong and it's
very easy to prove to all relatives on
earth that they are wrong okay
and the reason they are all wrong
they're irrational individuals okay is
that wait is using that term their
instantaneous wait is instantaneous why
is wait instantaneous because weight is
location dependent wait is location
dependent an astronaut moves at each a
tenth of an inch a billionth of an inch
forward towards the Earth is where he
changes instantaneously to use that term
and will not explain that in two seconds
here's so give me a give me a little
give me a little bit of time I'll get
there okay your weight changes
instantaneously that means that relative
is wrong there's they they talk about
traveling faster than the speed of light
or slower than the speed of light that's
because there's
thinking that something has to travel
that's the problem that's why they're
wrong that's why they're irrational
because they're using the particle
hypothesis and they're saying that the
particle from the Sun cannot travel to
the earth instantaneously and right if
if if the universe were made of
particles it wouldn't work
wouldn't work because weight has to
change instantaneously soon as the earth
moves an inch closer to the Sun it
already has a different weight with
respect to the Sun and you can't do that
with particles and that's the problem
the problem is in other words to put it
in reverse
it's the instantaneous change in weight
that destroys general relativity because
relativity is based on the field concept
and and it's all these branches of
mathematical physics all these branches
rely on the particle so they want to
explain everything with particle with
something traveling okay that's where
the problem is you cannot explain it
with particles you cannot explain it
with traveling that's why you cannot
explain wait the relativistic or
mathematical physics way okay
okay so where do we go after Newton well
from Newton we went to I mean you know
there were other people here but here we
go to a light stein and friends okay and
what do they come up with well they made
a mess a total mess of time and motion
completely first they have motions
through nothing you know
you move through space now you can't
boot throat space you can only move
through molasses you can move through
sand you can move through water you can
move through air you can move through a
medium if there is no medium you are not
moving through the thing because it's
not a thing space is not a thing space
is absolutely nothing that which has no
shape you cannot move through space you
move to some object you move to the
when you move to the Sun or towards
Jupiter you have to move towards objects
people never learned to speak properly
and they say oh we moved through space
so I'm in space now you can't be in
space because space is not a container
and this is part of the language problem
that these people introduced with other
mathematics okay motion through time I
don't know how you move through time how
do you move through time go back and
kill your grandfather you know kind of
thing how do you move through time take
the time tunnel is that how you move
through time time is a medium that you
cut across you slice in half as you move
through it is that what time is so the
language is irrational all that language
is Russian that's okay in ordinary
speech don't bring it into science don't
bring into physics Mochis motion changes
the rate of time you know here you have
your twin brother and he goes off to the
stars comes back he's younger than you
so his motion just the fact of him
moving change time for him as for you
you know two different observers but now
we're not talking about observers now
we're talking about reality this guy
comes you know younger than your looks
like your grandson easier to a brother
you know yeah sure maybe in in Hollywood
please explain the metamorphosis the
physical process that's what I need okay
time is a component of the surface or
interior of the 40 universe within which
we live right so you know we talked
about four-dimensional space-time and
you say well that's because you need
four number lines to locate a point
within space-time right and but that's
not true
see good ol Stephen Hawking in his book
a brief history of time he says he
cannot imagine four-dimensional space
for that menschell space-time he was
referring to he's analyzing space-time
he says he cannot imagine it well he's
talking in terms of three dimensional he
says he can imagine a three-dimensional
something okay you can imagine a
three-dimensional box
he cannot imagine a four-dimensional box
what is he saying he say
it's got four 90-degree angles to it and
of course we cannot picture that so so
when when they talk about that they
twist the language on you that you they
insinuate that the tie in about four
coordinates converging upon a point okay
but then what they're really referring
to is trying to imagine anything that is
like that that has length width and
height and a fourth dimension
perpendicular to those three and they
say well yeah you cannot imagine that of
course not
and so yeah time in that sense becomes
kind of weird because now now if time is
something to do with motion and time
becomes this dimension that we cannot
even imagine or define for that matter
well then yeah we come out of those
conferences not understanding squat
that's that's what it is
okay and time slows down in accelerates
okay depending on how fast you run if
you run close to the speed of light well
time slows down and so on you know and
then you have you know what walls been
raised and beams but is that about well
he had Arthur Eddington he proved that
Einstein was right when uh the first guy
to prove Einstein right and the way he
did it he said look you have this beam
of light from a faraway star and it
bends it curves around the gravity well
created by the Sun the Sun weighs down
space time it bends it right and you
have this gray that's been go around the
problem is there's no physical object
called gray or physical object called
being what they're talking about is it
is a shower of bullets they're talking
about photons so the correct word is
swerve or deflected you can say that our
photon was deflected by the wall of
curved wall of space you can say that
but you cannot say that you bent time so
bent I'm sorry that you bent light that
you bent the beam of light and so so
we've got a problem here because
language is important here it's
important not be
we're trying to beat up on semantics but
because the concept is wrong you cannot
say that you bet light if light is a
photon if one little photon represents
light you cannot say you bet like
because that's not what they're talking
about they're saying that though the
photon swerved or deflect was deflected
by the wall from its rectilinear path as
Newton would say okay so so the
language's is crucial
okay well the we start there with the
irrationality of mathematical physics no
we went ahead with mr. Niels Bohr and
his friends okay the people from quantum
what did they come up with well they
came up with tachyons
for example they travel faster than
light even those special relativity says
nothing in travel faster in line they
say yes over here and then when they're
over here they how we clean our butts
with the speed of light we can go faster
so what are we supposed to conclude I
mean they had to invent this particle to
explain certain things and these
particles appeared in peer-reviewed
journals in in in articles they're
allowed to put that stuff even though on
the other side they'll say well nothing
can travel faster than light so we have
contradiction people just live with the
contradiction say yeah that's okay no
problem we love tachyons they come from
the future whatever you know and then we
have the yo-yo effect we have negative
momentum transfer you throw the ball and
instead of pushing it away as you would
think so it carries negative motion it
delivers negative motion and the pizza
comes towards you so if you want to pull
on your pizza it you don't have to get
an elongated you know rope and just tug
it over no you just throw a ball at it
and the pizza will come over it's
negative mood just make sure the ball
has negative motion that's what it's got
to deliver okay in tangible action at a
distance well we have entanglement and
you have this particle over here which
affects this one over there right and
then they claim there's nothing in
between that simply this particle moves
in some way and somehow affects the
other one
oh I call that what spirits they call an
energy I caught spirits because what
they're doing is black magic they're not
giving you a mechanism they're saying
this particle effects that one so we
have instantaneous motion which they
just denied now they're they're bringing
back saying there's instantaneous motion
because you know if windows clockwise
the other one is counterclockwise if you
turn the one that was going clockwise if
you turn that one counter clockwise the
other one instantaneously turns
clockwise so we do have instantaneous
motion and what happened to the speed of
light to the fastest in the universe the
one day Einstein proved and etc.etc out
the window that's what happened to it
then we have bodyless movement we have
the photon it's got no mass no
relativistic massively it's got no mass
and no and no no rest mass okay and it's
got no nobody it's a point particle so
we have a nothing called the photon
bundle of energy or whatever and it
moves it moves at the speed of light
300,000 kilobits per second so some some
weird things that we got out there right
then we have the movement of concepts I
call I talked about that the other day
I'm not going to go in detail with that
but we had we have mass energy you know
you move a mass you transfer energy you
transfer information now how's that for
transferring concept they transfer
information they they extend the field
they move the charge all these concepts
are moving around all around us you get
a duck because you never know when one
of these concepts might hit you in that
face you know and yeah we have the
Warped wall been raised and beams also
okay so where does all this take us well
I just wanted to show that motion is
still very weird time is still very
weird we have no idea what those are
because the mathematicians never defined
them and they're fine with that because
they can write a book like Stephen
Hawking wrote his book you know 100 and
a b-plus pages and he talks about time
and he never did find overtime so it's
it's great because you can talk about
time you can use it in equations as
seconds minutes hours years whatever and
you never have to define it so we never
know what we're talking about but we all
talk about it
time is wood one of the clock measures
or reads or whatever okay so I just want
to end this with this notion of the
principle of equivalence okay I had a
big problem trying to understand why the
principle of equivalence works and he
just used that as as that he just
mentioned it as a principle you just
took it as unfaith he says look there's
this principle that the inertial mass is
equal to gravitational mass under
certain circumstances and he could not
explain it he just said I'm gonna take
it as a principle and just accept it
that that is so ok and this is what the
principle of equivalence says ok here
you have accelerated reference frame in
one on your left and rest mass and
gravitational in a gravitational field
okay on the right the first one deals
with force equals mass times
acceleration which is Newton's second
law and the second one deals with his
gravitational equation and the first
thing I want you to see here is that the
arrows are always in the direction of
push okay so when the rocket on the Left
pushes upward the ball comes down okay
and the right hand when the ball falls
to earth is because something is
allegedly pushing it from above okay
there's no mention of pull and here you
have maybe a better picture of that
here's just a picture of it okay from
the same phone you can see that when the
rocket goes up and they talk about force
equals mass times acceleration all the
arrows are pushing the ball downwards
they never thought of anything other
than push because mathematical physics
is a particle theory all of it 150
percent of it whether it's general
relativity and it's field concept
whether it's quantum mechanics and it's
tiny little balls of the you know
different names of balls that they have
in the standard model it's always push
that's why they could never figure out
action at a distance okay and so yeah
I'd say I had a big problem with the
principle of equivalence here because he
says if you're in a rocket and you're
being pushed at 9.8 do you want or 9.8
meters per second square right upwards
by that's the acceleration of your
rocket and you let go of the ball and
the ball will come to the floor at that
speed or at that acceleration rate and
if you're on the right and you're you're
simply let go the ball on earth and
it'll fall with the same acceleration
towards the center of the earth so he
said these two things seem to be
equivalent I don't know why but I'm just
gonna declare it as a principle that
they are equivalent yeah and of course
he could never figure it out never would
not with particles because again you
have problems explain anything with
particles with discrete particles how do
we explain it in science in real physics
okay here we go
this is the explanation for the
principle of equivalence and it's that
if we have an atom that red one there
and it's at a given distance from the
earth there's a certain number of ropes
at that distance connected between that
atom in every atom on earth how you draw
them all by the way okay and so can you
tell whether the ball is going upwards
leaving the earth or whether it's coming
downwards well under the rope model it's
no biggie it's it's not even a you know
it's for babies a 10 year old can figure
this out the reason those two equations
are equivalent under those circumstances
is the same number of ropes converged
upon that atom irrespective of whether
it's going out or coming in at that
location at that location you have a
certain number of ropes okay further
down there are more ropes that widen up
yeah because as it approaches the Rose
fan out as he goes farther
you know converge upon themselves so
they given distance if we could freeze
the universe we should be able to count
every rope in there and say it's got
gazillion ropes plus one whatever so it
doesn't matter if the thing is going
outwards or inwards that's the reason
the cause the mechanism that underlies
the principle of equivalence the number
of ropes it never occurred to them that
Mother Nature does pull and they never
figured out how to pull because they
never figured out the ropes and why did
they figure out the ropes because they
said well I can't see them and I can't
touch them and it would be all tangled I
mean nobody even proposed it because
they they probably dismiss it right
offhand say well yeah we're not gonna do
that right and yeah that's what it is
an object is not that which you can
touch or see it's that which has shape
the Rope has shape therefore it's a
physical object now do the ropes touch
each other do the ropes cross each other
can you touch a row can you see a rope
that's a separate matter okay we've got
an object that has shape okay we're done
and and what we're saying is that
gravity is the number of ropes
converging upon an atom at a given
distance that's why your weight changes
instantaneously as soon as you move one
inch closer to the earth the ropes
phantom you know that atom is now
connected to the gazillions of atoms but
now the atoms of the earth are not one
behind the other now they're you know
they've kind of separated with respect
to your distance to your location okay
and that's why that's why the principle
of equivalence works it's the mechanism
underlying principle of equivalence so
yeah if the sudden word that disappears
this very moment now it would not take
two years for you to get the message we
would be running out of the solar system
instantaneously because the ropes from
every atom on earth would have nothing
to which they would be bound the only
reason the earth goes around the Sun is
the Sun you know swings the earth around
itself through the gazillions of ropes
that interconnect their mutual
if you magically God comes in makes the
Sun disappear every atom in there all
these ropes are just angling there
they're not tied to anything you start
flying out and so do all the other
planets so no the notion that general
relativity has that you know it takes 8
minutes because for the information to
reach you because nothing can travel
faster than light
that's mentally [ __ ] because it's
based on the particle hypothesis on
traveling
weight is not a traveling mechanism
weight is a location mechanism the
closer you are to an object the more the
ropes fan out and the stronger your
acceleration towards that object that's
why it's acceleration is a distance
phenomenon square of a distance
phenomena right and and yeah and that
also explains the principle of
equivalence if you're at a given
distance right and you stop the universe
at that moment you you freeze the
universe and you count the number of
ropes of that atom to all the atoms that
make up the earth you should be able to
count every single rope that is not what
will we call effective ropes and that's
a long story but effective ropes when
that atom gets closer to the object to
the earth for example now it's got more
effective ropes why because one atom is
no longer behind the mast behind the
other yeah okay
we'll continue with this line of attack
on the mathematical establishment we're
gonna continue hopefully with some
geometry and Aristotle and some of his
friends from the Greek world was here on
Sunday bye bye